you may not have noticed but i have been
cursed with an unusual affliction
he's a pothead
get it
let's see if he actually does he
actually say i'm a pothead alas
judge me not by the shape of my head but
by the deliciousness of the soup inside
okay they went there they went there
people of the internets hello and
welcome back to death's door this is
part two in our let's play series
and i am having a blast with this game
so far guys you see we played for about
51 minutes there apparently we are 8.4
of the way through
where we left off is we actually just
found what they refer to as the death's
door this uh big bird he kind of like
tricked us at least i think he tricked
us
and so when i exited last night after i
finished up playing part one
it said it would auto save but that it
will take you back to the most recent
door so i want you guys to know i i
haven't played any since then
but this is how it kind of handles when
you save and come back so it just puts
me right here
and it doesn't you know i don't start
exactly where i left off so we're gonna
have to remember where we were and make
our way back up there which i think i
know the way because we had unlocked a
couple of different
shortcuts
wait is it this way right here i think
it's up this ladder here
okay so here's where we left off i'm
pretty sure we were right up here
and this guy
tricked us okay he's still here waiting
so that door up there is is the death's
door
i feel like that is what we're working
toward but they wanted me to go to the
north to the witches
abode the urn witch something like that
i think she's called
which is this way so we're gonna head
back over here
and get ready to face off with this
witch
all right so i've already done this
lever no i haven't okay let's do this
all right so that makes it to where
did that just open up another shortcut
oh yeah it did
so that connects to this place right
here all right really interesting level
design so far
i'm liking how everything seems
connected here and it's all
tying back into that little starting
area
okay so let's read this one more time
so this way to the the urn witch that's
what they call it the earned witch's
mansion is where we're going right now
so it had three little symbols on above
the uh doorway there
all right here we are the urn which is
mansion
okay this this has the feeling of a
dungeon-like area here
let's go ahead and pick this up
so which way do we want to go first is
there anything we can do to interact
with these
i don't think so
so that one right there is where we came
in and then there's only two paths left
or right so i'm gonna take the right
path here
i feel like that guy's about to charge
me
so weird how they don't disappear
you just lay there
all right let's hit this lever here
okay all that did was turn on the torch
right there oh okay wait do we have a
zelda style thing here do i need to
is there a way i can shoot the arrow
through oh man
so if we could shoot the arrow through
and light the other one but i guess not
okay so this guy's still out that's good
now i feel like these lamps might be
important too both of those are lighting
up pink right now okay so that torch is
on those lamps are on that torch is on
all right now let's make our way through
here maybe there's another switch
oh my goodness i thought this was a guy
right here just like a statue apparently
okay so that wait wait wait wait a
second
push this lever here and hopefully that
will light the other door
there we go and that opens the way
gotcha
okay nothing in here looks like we have
to go through
and down we go into the depths of the
earned witch's mansion
what do we have here
oh man look at the shadows love that
oh wait this takes us back outside
okay knocking that over actually gave me
one of my arrows back okay hold on
though before we before we go out here i
want to make sure that i could i walk to
the end of that hall was there something
else
nope just the door oh look at that man
it looks like a giant keyhole right
there
little uh reflection on the on the wall
all right well i guess we'll go back
this way and looks like the pots come
back after you just
walk through the room
all right we can go over there and grab
that seed
i think we already have one
see it should pop up in the bottom okay
yeah so now we're at two
good deal
the seeds are what allow you to restore
health so far that's the only method
i've found that or dying if you die and
then you come back your health is
restored
so you have to find those little plants
plant the seed
and then you can uh the seed gives you
health
or the plant gives you health rather
look at that little pot sitting on top
there
all right so i guess i don't know if
this is all part of the mansion or not
oh dude can i just
no okay
it's about to you know i would have to
test it just like in the beginning we
had to test
oh wait is he giving me a hint do i need
to shoot the arrow through the fire
let's read this
burn your weapons and spread joy there
we go guys
[Music]
nice i figured it out from the statue
but
that's good to know so that is actually
how you interact and open these things
so there were i think we've seen two of
those so far in the early parts of the
game
so when we're back over there now we
know but i i don't know if there were
any
fires nearby hopefully there were
the state of the urnwitch
[Music]
oh it lit that torch too okay
and that opens the way do these give us
little yes those give us our magic
arrows back too
[Music]
so far doesn't seem like there's any
little pickups that i have to worry
about when i'm
destroying items like that it's really
just a matter of oh look at this secret
it's just a matter of
making sure you have your maximum arrows
available and i am over 400 so i could
buy another upgrade back in the little
hub area if i wanted to
i don't think i can do i have the
ability to
how about this
no okay what about the charge attack
nope all right fine
so you can see how it's kind of glinting
that little uh shine that passes over
that wall
this way to the iron witch's mansion
okay so we weren't in the in her actual
mansion yet all right well
this is her estate
[Music]
you already know what's gonna happen but
i have i have to find out
okay so you take a hit
and then you instantly sink and you
can't get back okay so there's got to be
some sort of power up or ability that
we're going to get that allows us to
either swim through the water or cross
over water something like that
all right big battle coming up guys
big battle when we activate this
oh wait
should i have activated it first
oh hello there my beak-faced fellow
it is quite unusual to see one of your
kind upon these isles i imagine you must
be here for a soul
not me i should hope anyway it seems our
paths have intersected at an opportune
moment you may not have noticed but i
have been cursed with an unusual
affliction
he's a pothead
get it
let's see if he actually does he
actually say i'm a pothead alas
judge me not by the shape of my head but
by the deliciousness of the soup inside
okay they went there they went there
pothead where are my manners i'm very
pleased to make your acquaintance speak
face
oh wow it would seem that my journey has
reached an impasse
i haven't been able to overcome the
obstacles ahead and unlock the iron
gates if you would help me move on i
should be indebted to you and we could
push forward together
all right buddy i'll try to help you hey
there's another pot end right
potheads all over this this area right
here
okay before i do any of that though i
feel like we need to
activate this right here
oh that's just another door so that's
not the thing
okay it it looks like
one of those areas where all the enemies
uh come rushing out at you for for a
time but this just takes me back to the
main area so let's let's actually go
ahead and go through i want to see where
this one leads
because if it leads uh okay yeah it's a
completely different spot right here in
front of this little
all of doors is where we're at right now
we've been commissioned headquarters all
right well i should definitely go back
and upgrade
i think i'm gonna do my speed which they
refer to as haste in this game welcome
to the soul vault would you like to
increase your combat abilities why yes i
would
so it would cost 600 to do strength
again but i'm gonna do haste i think i'm
gonna go strength and haste all the way
to max
his dexterity ability to attack with
speed and precision raising this will
allow the reaper to charge their melee
see i think it primarily applies to the
ranged
and charged attack
and increase the speed at which melee
attacks can be chained together yeah i
mean that could be helpful too but
raising this will give the reaper a
greater base speed faster dodges and
less cooldown yeah i'm gonna go there
all right so now it looks like same cost
across the board so after you upgrade
one then it's gonna go to 600 and so on
see where it goes from there
[Music]
all right so let's go back to the door
i mean i don't really notice like
it doesn't really feel that much faster
make sure there's not anything i need to
do
like to enable it you know so i don't
have any giant souls yet i need three
giant souls
all right let's go back to the state of
the urn which here
now see i don't okay so also going back
through there
interesting looks like that restores
your health as well so there's really no
reason for me to plant the seed though
when i don't need help
okay got another orb over here which i
think we can just
oh there's another one of those walls
though that we don't know how to
knock down just yet let's head over here
make sure there's nothing behind this
lots of little secrets so far in this
game not even like
leading to some big item at least not so
far
but
the way the camera works you kind of got
to be on alert for
little hidden paths you can find
all right so let's try to go over here
first i still don't think we have the
ability to
yeah we don't have the ability to get
past that
[Music]
oh what is this right here does that
give us magic
oh
okay so
two things happen there
it hurt me
but also
it knocked down that barrier
oh we got guys with arrows now
[Music]
i wonder if i can pick up these and move
them
i don't think so but what if i do this
yeah destroy it from afar
dude those things look just like wiz
robes
especially the ones in breath of the
wild i mean it looks like that exact
design
okay got that guy done
another harsher here oh i didn't mean to
hit that one fortunately i think i was
far enough away
the garden of peace yeah right
oh we blew it up with him right beside
it that was awesome
okay so
might as well plant here
go ahead and consume okay that restores
our health
all right so to get to that one we need
to be on the other side
i don't think there's any way to shoot
the arrow over at least not yet
take out the archers first man
[Music]
oh goodness
all these ranged attacks
yikes okay we gotta get out of here
be very cautious with this guy
[Music]
okay that one's out
one more
oh it's hiding in that corner
i think one more arrow might get rid of
him yep there we go
okay
explode this right here let's get our
arrows back by destroying this
okay now i don't like running around
with just one
health bar
so the problem is i can't go back to
this one see how it's like already
wilted
i need to go back to that other one
which i didn't plant any at just yet
because see i don't want to go back
through the door if i go back through
the main door
then all those enemies are going to
reset
which they weren't too difficult but
yeah yeah this way this way
right here it is okay perfect
[Music]
plant that seed right there go ahead and
consume okay max our help
[Music]
see there's none of those things over
here
to be able to destroy that wall right
there
unless it's hidden somewhere
all right so we were able to destroy
that one
and now we can go here
[Music]
okay so three hits on the archers
[Music]
oh i did not mean to do that
hey go ahead try to hit me
[Music]
all right three hits on that archer
whiz robe that's just that's just what
i'm calling them from now
on these are whiz robes
[Music]
all right now can i move these things
oh man it'd be great if i could move it
if you could pick it up and take it to
another spot so we only got
lost one uh health bar right there it's
not too bad
considering all the enemies
yeah i don't guess there's really any
reason for me to destroy those right now
oh wait but the gate
oh here there's a lever
it's like wait why is the gate still up
sometimes it it
[Music]
there we go sometimes it goes down just
when you like destroy all the enemies
from an area
that time it wanted me to actually pull
the lever there
oh this dude came over here okay so most
impressive
i'll make haste and ignite the second
lantern all right
[Music]
i'm guessing i need to go the other way
for that one
[Music]
because i went right
in this little courtyard area so i need
to go on the left side now
[Music]
okay we've got oh we need to light the
torch
[Music]
oh wait shoot it right there
gotta get lined up just right
oh enemies
okay i'm taking the archers for granted
is that it
that's it
so now we're gonna shoot the arrow here
and shoot the arrow here
torch is lit gate is open
okay that gate is still closed
make your way on the left side here
gonna need to use this through the
open gateway
oh no more enemies
i'd rather have these guys in the
archers i think
[Music]
okay so you gotta when you see the
little charge you can see the archer
kind of charge beforehand the
the um
the arrow itself will have like this
little light charge on it
that's when he's about to shoot
[Music]
all right more enemies
oh the wiz rogue dude
i don't like this man
what if his arrow went through
i'd be so mad
the wiz robes aren't too bad if you
start hitting them
okay wait for it
there's the charge dodge
all right take him out
and we need more health the bad thing is
we don't have any seeds
even if we were to come upon one of
those
[Music]
oh wait i feel like i saw one over here
though
oh man yep there it is
the garden of joy
was the other one peace i think
oh we've got a little puzzle here
okay so
destroy that
destroy that okay that lets us through
now i need to get the flames
to go through here to this one
and then i can send them over here
oh no
oh no okay it's just the wiz ropes
dodge
[Music]
that's almost done
[Music]
all right now charge this bad boy up
the gate is lowered okay i'm just gonna
make sure that i didn't pick up a seat
maybe i picked up one and didn't realize
it
nope okay
orb just randomly over there
it's got to be a hidden path to get to
that
let's see i'm just gonna
i gotta spend a ton of time looking for
it but
it feels like there should be a way to
get there from here
so you never know in games like this
maybe it's like a metroid style thing
where i just don't have the ability yet
to be able to get over there
or is it an actual puzzle thing that i
just need to look a little more
carefully
because i feel like you should be able
to cut through somewhere like underneath
here
and then go under
like through that stone and then emerge
over there but
i'm not seeing anything so
on we go
oh it could be over here though
[Music]
oh there's a seed yes
i'm going back right now
even though i guess death in this game
it really doesn't hurt you that much
because i die i died once and it
it was in the beginning because i i
jumped off
twice once on purpose another time by
accident
so i only had two health bars when i got
to the boss but let's go ahead and
consume that
but yeah it didn't seem to really punish
you that much you're just gonna have to
restart the area see um like if i died
right here though i don't know how many
of these doors would be open
so i'm not sure how the autosave works
like if they if they want to make you go
back through and do all that again
okay wait so there's nothing else over
here
is there not any way to get in there
this way
guess not
all right well let's go back and talk to
the pod head
and see if he has any guidance for us
after we pull this lever right here that
should light the torch
yep right there gate is open
all right buddy you ready
hurrah we can now venture onward my
steadfast companion
but first we should grant ourselves a
moment of respite
come sit with me a while oh i bet this
would have restored my health
probably would have restored my health
if i had just waited as i mentioned upon
our meeting i was not always quite so
earthenware in appearance
this strange curse was visited upon me
by the wicked old lady who resides in
the mansion beyond these lavish gardens
i imagine you are here for her are you
not
surely her soul must be swollen and ripe
for the reaping due to her
unnaturally extended years i desire not
but to confront the old witch
and request she undo her ceramic deed
and restore me to my former handsome
self
i was quite the looker you know
all right buddy i'm gonna try to help
you soup
the bird says no no
so be it let us push shawn once more
i don't know man like that would be kind
of weird eating soup from like his
that's his head essentially he seemed
quite adept at cutting down our foes so
i shall let you bear the brunt of it i
shall bring up the rear and meet you at
the mansion gates okay so that's how
it's going to be
[Music]
oh
okay whatever i just did sounded like a
creature was in pain
[Music]
wait is that
oh
interesting
so that little orb that flew out of it
it's kind of deceiving because it looks
like a health pickup
that's why i was confused at first
but you can hit it back with your sword
oh yeah let's do it right here let's go
right here we're going to shoot this
with an arrow and then hit it at those
enemies
oh direct hit on him
doesn't look like it did too much damage
dodge that
[Music]
man i wish hitting the arrow guys like
would stop them from
readying the arrows but it doesn't they
just keep on going
all right got rid of you
[Music]
go ahead and just play that just so we
can get by
[Music]
oh man that totally looks like a spot
where you'd be able to go under
it's like some
[Music]
boxes right here
[Music]
okay so we can pass through there freely
oh this has got to be a secret over here
come on there's got to be something
hidden there back here
nothing
oh
there's another enemy though
all right so let's go back this way
oh i wonder if i need to like use the
[Music]
torch light for anything
let's see what it says right
here or which is mansion still okay
don't have any seeds
[Applause]
[Music]
oh okay this has got to be a secret
right here
yeah there we go
all right pick up on that and we can hit
this lever
brings back the ladder
and up we go
all right so we're only down one health
bar right now not too bad
i feel like i missed something over here
though
[Music]
didn't i miss something this way
yeah yeah this way right here
what does this say
the garden of love
so we got what love joy and peace so far
oh there's a seed right there let's go
now this feels like a big time puzzle
right here
i don't want to just start breaking
those pots the family tomb
and then we've got a little spot where
you can destroy right here if i had one
of those
little blue pots
[Music]
where does this go does this just lead
us back to the main no it doesn't
okay there's a gate right there okay
let's push this lever
so now it does it connects back so
that's that's where i was heading oh no
no no no i'm not ready yet pothead
oh there my friend i would make a good
statue would i not ha
i'm not ready to go in yet though
so here we are
this edifice may look unassuming even be
calming however keep your wits about you
untold dangers await us inside now let
us die from the precipice of adventure
and enter the belly of the beast
together no no i'm not going yet
i'll be there in a second dude
i'll be there in a second pothead just
wait
there's so much over here to explore i
don't want to miss anything
like that that family tomb area
[Music]
i really feel like there's got to be
some significance to all of those
pots
[Music]
like i said i don't want to destroy them
but
you know what what if i just stand here
[Music]
whoa
okay this is definitely a puzzle
let's try this
oh man i was hoping the arrow would go
through
[Music]
oh dude
this is fascinating
okay
so it's not a speed thing i was thinking
maybe i needed to just like quickly
destroy them maybe maybe it still is i
don't know maybe it's an order thing
but dude this would
be you imagine how hard it'll be to
guess the order
[Music]
correctly on this
[Music]
oh and they all come back
okay i wonder if there's a hint anywhere
did i read this already right here
yeah garden of love
i mean is it possible to make these into
a heart
[Music]
oh wait wait wait what if i just destroy
this one
and oh no i didn't mean to destroy that
one
yeah just go ahead rebuild
now why did the middle one not rebuild
[Music]
i think it was just a timing thing
yeah see how that one did
[Music]
i got nothing
man i got nothing we'll try later
all right let's go and join the guy
again it could be one of those things
that i just don't have the capability of
being able to solve yet you know
there might be an ability that i i find
later in the game that's going to help
me or maybe there's a hint in here
that will kind of give me a clue
all right what's up dude you going ahead
i'll guard the door
okay sure
oh no
okay so destroying those open the door
[Music]
ceramic manor the earn witch's mansion
oh dude and they're doing it in here too
[Music]
let's activate this door oh yeah this
makes a lot of sense i should definitely
go back
if for no other reason than just to
restore that that one bar of health
right
so i don't think i have enough to yeah i
only have 187 so usually
no reason to
can't buy anything but it does restore
that little bar of health
all right so we know we need like fire
to open up these things looks like an
elevator right here
maybe some type of vent possible that we
could get in there
all the portraits on the wall featuring
various pod heads
there you go
[Music]
oh man those reform too
so maybe it's something that you can't
solve until you destroy the witch
yeah pretty sure we need a key for that
which we do not have yet
oh man look at this door right here
ancient door spirit living reaper i
hunger for souls
well all righty then let's go this
way oh my goodness dude look at this
room
gorgeous
whoa spin attack
you know what this is making him think
of like beauty and the beast all the
stuff coming to life
oh that one
so the other one wasn't an actual enemy
it was just the one so i got lucky i
went to the right one first try
[Music]
okay that's one that we can destroy
what
[Music]
that one behaved very differently
from the other ones that we've seen so
far
and so i don't think i don't think i
have anything to
set that on fire like we need to
all right we got fire right there though
oh and lots of ladders
[Music]
okay i see where we need to be
[Music]
grab this scene while we're over here
though
all right that brings us to two seats
nothing else
there might be another torch oh yeah we
gotta like that one
there we go
and that's gonna give us the key
excellent
[Music]
dude look at all these pots in here
yeah i knew that one was gonna be
oh and then we somehow have to destroy
the one on the desk right there
interesting
[Music]
okay so let's go upstairs maybe we can
drop down on it somehow
dude this area is awesome oh no that was
oh there's four
so we've just taken out two
two more
yep there's one
oh i overshot it
yeah i think you gotta drop off land on
that table and then shoot the arrow
that's my guess
oh wait wrong way oh wait what's back
here though
anything
oh come on that'd be a perfect place to
hide one of the little orbs
[Music]
would be a perfect place to hide the orb
dude
all right let's try i'm not gonna roll
this time i'm just gonna walk off there
we go
all right door is open
now we proceed
oh dude i told you man
i called it in part one it's always the
fire that destroys the spider webs
oh man these
restore themselves as well
[Music]
okay we got some fire over here that we
need to light
down an area where we could plant a seed
if we get in trouble
okay so i'm gonna go here
[Music]
light that one
light all the ones that we can on the
outside first
so we got that one right there
that one right there okay now do we use
that one yep like this over here
and we're out so let's see if i destroy
the pots does it give me yep
gives me the arrows back so i got three
arrows now
and blast you over here
destroys the door and on we go all right
well
you know what happens in this room
i mean you could just tell right
they make it obvious that's fine though
oh okay
[Music]
okay okay
wait what oh i gotta hit him in the
front all right
[Music]
watch out for that spin attack
stop chasing me
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah you know what to do with that oh
oh my gosh it just melted him
what
just like instant ko when that green orb
hit him i don't know if it just worked
out that way where it was like his hit
points had been depleted
or if that is the only way to take him
out
man this whole place is kind of eerie
you hear like the whispers everywhere we
go
they've stopped for now but
oh what in the world free soul
it appears we've been abandoned here
i don't think anyone is coming to open
the door
[Music]
i don't know what just happened but that
seemed a little bit sad
oh and he's going to power up the door
for me okay
there's another seed in there that i
totally missed yep there he is his dead
skeleton
okay so i don't think is there anything
else i could do in this this room i
don't think so
all right moving on moving on
see if anything has changed in here
i kind of want to
okay something has definitely changed
because there's a giant lady here now oh
that's her
hello dear quite unexpected to see a
crow around this place
does this mean the deal is off
what brings an adorable fellow like you
into my little house
oh
oh
i'm kind of sitting here to uh
to kill you
dude i thought she was about to attack
right there she's just like okay i'm
leaving goodbye
oh man you know what i should have done
i should have went over here and shot
her with a flaming arrow
oh my goodness
okay oh so that leads back in here all
right
dude look at that man no health
used so far
all right so let's grab this seed
and then we're gonna use our key to
unlock the door
wait but what did we get another key
hold on hold on oh there's two spots
where do we want to use the key i'm
gonna go here
because i feel like this is kind of like
a side area
this might be something uh
this might give us like a power-up of
some kind
oh man look at all these dudes
yeah i get that charge attack in there
no
all right so that opens the door we got
another seed up top over there
let's go ahead and get that i think
that'll bring us up to three seeds that
we could
use
that's why i'm i'm not too worried about
taking that hit
let's go and pick that up
go through here oh dude look at this
area so we got another key
now i'm kind of wondering did i even
need to go in here at all like did i
ever need to do this
because i already had a key i could have
just used the token the big door but
[Music]
who knows maybe there's gonna be
something in here that makes it worth my
time
see where does this lead in here just a
bunch of urns
oh another seed
oh we're up to five now okay
oh yeah this is a completely different
area
yikes all right that was bad
okay we're down to two hits
what in the world
[Music]
oh
what just happened
were they invisible
oh wait look at the reflection
[Music]
oh my goodness dude
is it over here
i don't know where to shoot
[Music]
so wait i feel like it should be
oh
dude what is happening
oh
what
pray at the shrine absolutely
i was overthinking it man i was thinking
like okay it's reflecting so it's on the
ceiling no they just want me to just
swing right there the ancient shrine
offers you a shard from a magic crystal
collecting four will raise your magic
capacity beyond its limits
all right so that brings us up to oh we
just have one of those man i thought we
had two
i was thinking of the crystal shark the
green one so we got one of the greens
and one of the pink
pink or red looks more pink to me but
all right well okay that was definitely
worth
that little detour
and we're not done yet there's more
areas up here to check out oh my
goodness this is her bedroom
[Music]
she's already gotten the heck out of
here though
i took one swing at her she's like
uh what are you doing
uh what are you doing dude
[Music]
she did not like that that's for sure
okay now how do we get that one just
shoot through the hole here
[Music]
oh you can't oh wait i can land on her
bed though
all right there we go all four
[Music]
unlocked oh man
lots of enemies down here
[Music]
go ahead swing at me
[Music]
oh no
get out of the way
[Music]
oh dude
i didn't know that those were uh we need
to oh yes perfect time for the plant
like it was hard to tell which of those
were the uh little pots that were going
to explode
and which ones were just the standard
pots so i wasn't expecting a hit right
there
all right well good thing
another one of these guys
oh
and they're adding uh regular enemies
too though
oh got them all
okay that answers my question it's not
the green ball that ko's him
it's a combination
just worked out that way the first time
oh dude you know what i think these guys
are gonna keep coming out
until i finish him off
it's my guess anyway
[Music]
i'm trying to get a charge back in
see i feel like
i was gonna say that'd be a good time to
go after the big guy but when i only had
one out here
it seems like they just keep spawning
man
oh i got hit by that
oh no oh no
no
dude that's only our second death of the
game oh man
okay how far back are we gonna have to
go
so it puts us right here at the start
and then i need to go up here
and then here is the way i went i have
that other key though like i could go
yeah see i don't need to do any of this
i'm not gonna fight those guys oh good
i'm so glad it unlocked okay
so that's not too bad it saves all of
that progress i don't need to do all
those puzzles over again
oh but that guy's coming after me
okay then we went to her bedroom here
we went to here yeah here we go down
here all right that's not too bad
so one charge hit and then a regular hit
takes out those guys
[Music]
all right here we go let's do this
i'm going to focus the big guy this time
let's see if it keeps adding other
minions like if it ever adds more than
two i'm just gonna try not to kill them
because if it doesn't add more than two
then i might as well just like
i was gonna say i might as well just
like leave the two out but sometimes
they're just gonna be in the way
naturally
hit that green or back at him
not bad not bad
oh i was about to say i think he's about
done
oh nice a little slow-mo right there to
finish him off
and another spirit
all right let's free that soul
i'm starting to question the authority
of our lord of doors although it might
be a bit late given that i am deceased
all right so you're gonna go and help
power up that door it looks like we need
what two more
so we need four total to power this door
and we already have another key so we
know exactly where we need to go
[Music]
and we only took one hit on there but i
don't even need to plant i can just
consume this one right here restore the
health oh there she is again
oh heavens my house is a mess
my beautiful urns shattered
i mean i must apologize for the state of
the house deary
i wasn't expecting guests
dude look at the way she follows me i'm
not even gonna try to hit you this time
you know
i'm just gonna leave
she's gonna leave because i know you're
just gonna
float away
oh i forgot oh it didn't hurt me though
somehow
okay so this is a room that we haven't
been in just yet oh wait hello a large
talking pot
shall we dance
oh you're gonna fight me oh jeez
oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
dude i feel like the arrow is really
gonna be helpful on this guy
[Music]
oh man he comes at you if you're close
to him see that's why i thought the
arrow is gonna be best
the pot's starting to break
dude you can only get like one hit in
right there
[Music]
i'm gonna get away
this guy takes a lot of hits
hey oh no
oh it dude if that one didn't hit i was
dead like if that didn't kill him i was
dead
[Music]
wow that was close
oh there's a lever over here i almost
didn't even see that
oh dude and it does open that up
remember i said in the beginning
we first started this level like that
kind of looks like a place where
we might go
all right so okay that opens the ladder
i want to see where that leads though
i'm assuming it just leads back into the
main area of the house right where you
first come in
yep oh that's awesome dude
it's like an elevator
[Music]
all right we still don't have any way to
set those on fire which i'm pretty sure
that's what's going to open
that elevator door the one right in the
middle
oh you know what we totally should have
healed right oh
look up there in the light
dude how do you get that
[Music]
i wonder if i shoot my arrow like
oh here we go
[Music]
not nearly as complex as i was
expecting it to be
oh geez
that definitely makes this harder
[Music]
man i feel like you're really starting
to use the arrows more
i might want to consider upgrading them
[Music]
i gotta remember man i only have one
health bar right now
looks like an item right here what is
this like a ring
you found an old engagement ring
now you just need to find someone who
would want to marry you oh that's it
okay
oh perfect timing on the plant
perfect timing
look at all this over here like these
green
interesting can't be destroyed
okay what if i
i want to get that orb i don't know if
i'm supposed to just like walk into the
light over there
or if you need to shoot it down
oh
okay not that
whatever i just did right there wrong
answer i do think you're supposed to
just drop like that though but maybe
over here on
on this side oh man
it's like throwing off my perspective
let me go ahead and get the
this right here
and this right here
okay so that opens that
oh wait can i just like
ah
there we go
about to say can i just hit that and it
falls down
nice okay we're over 400 again so we
could do another upgrade
or do we want to try and save up to 600
and and do either strength or haste
again oh i do not like this
i do not like this
i do not like this at all
let's light all these torches here
it's like a little maze
oh no two hits already from these guys
okay anything else over here nope
like that torch
what a cool area
wait didn't like the torch just
there we go
all right so what oh no
nice uh
all three of them taken out with that
charge attack
and then looks like there's a spider web
oh there's two ladders now though
there's that ladder over there and then
this ladder right here
oh
oh man i need to destroy a pot
to get my arrows back
there we go
okay so hold on then i want to see where
this one goes first
maybe that all just ties back around oh
no it doesn't completely different
okay let's go see where this one leads
oh this way
up we go
oh perfect glad i came back then oh 591
yeah we just need to save up
i think i'm gonna do strength again and
then focus on maybe the ranged because
upgrading haste like i barely notice any
difference
maybe it's way more than i realize but
i don't know doesn't feel like that huge
right now
okay two bars yeah i got a lot of seed
so i might as well go ahead and
go ahead and restore my health right
here
[Music]
oh another spirit
so i think we just need one more after
this
why did the door close how could we get
back
we're almost there buddy you charge it
up then we just need one more
one more and then we're gonna have that
door open and i'm guessing
i'm guessing after we open that door
we're gonna have to fight the witch
i don't know
oh there she is again oh goodness you're
not the cause of all this ruckus are you
i would not be very hospitable to any
beast who would mistreat my children
tread lightly reaper
yeah you know what
quiet
oh man
okay so we need to go back oh wait
what's this right here
yes
perfect we already have the key for this
unlock it
and on we go okay perfect perfect
perfect
oh wow this room's huge man
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what
oh wait i think it might be a little bit
higher yeah it is
[Music]
i gotta remember that those are the guys
that little purple ones damage you
oh dude how do you get
wait wait wait i think i see it i think
i see it can i just drop here and then
walk yes
oh you know what i should have done
while i was back in that main area i
definitely should have upgraded i went
back and upgraded
i'll do it before we go through the door
for sure
i think i might up my strength again
because we really want to
do lots of damage to her oh wait this
one right here
before
there we go okay that's two
there's about to be three
[Music]
oh you like that
back to back taking out both of them
there all right let's drop here
in the world
oh i didn't mean to do that
i'd like already started the charge
okay let's grab it go ahead and grab the
seed up here forgot to do that
and then we've only got that last little
uh pot down there
we got five of them again
[Music]
all right those guys aren't too bad
is there a little pot up here to plant
i feel like there was but oh
no okay i guess not
i guess not
[Music]
oh it's hoping you can just walk under
right there
okay the fact that all of these pots are
like
kind of healing themselves going back
together like that pot
those pots outside i'm pretty sure that
there's nothing we could have done right
there
pretty sure not a hundred percent sure
but pretty sure
okay we've got us ourselves a little
predicament here
i think i see the solution though
okay so the keys already open
[Music]
wait a second then what's the point of
oh wait that lets you get up there
i need to knock this light off again
nope
wait so what's the point of getting over
there then
i'm looking at that white platform on
top
because essentially that's what
this right here enables me to reach this
level
like there's got to be a point to
getting up this high right
[Music]
oh yeah there is
all right let's grab the key first and
then we'll
then we'll assess further
okay the lever right there
oh and then you have to use that okay to
get out
now it all makes
all right let's climb right here and
then we can drop down right here
[Music]
walk this way
[Music]
i was like there's got to be a reason
for that ladder up there
they just that ladder that dropped down
[Music]
ah and a ladder there so if we ever come
back to this room it'll be easy to yeah
we got five seats man i'm playing them
need to keep our health at max here oh
yeah good call good call
another one of these guys
oh we got the whiz robes though this
time
oh man
actually i think they're kind of easier
to contend with than me
i've tried to dodge man i'm getting too
greedy
i gotta stop being greedy you guys
there we go
just take your hits man i've played a
lot of dark souls a lot of bloodborne i
know how you gotta do it
you can't get too greedy
man am i really gonna die to this guy
there we go okay good we didn't
we didn't die to him all right and
there's the final spirit man
all right let's free his soul
she said i would live forever but with a
pot for a head
no thanks
i love like the little humor in this
game like you can tell it's obviously a
very serious game about death but then
they they make sure that they
interject that humor throughout as well
alright so
now we go back
now we go back to our friend the pothead
oh there she is again
well now little crow
you have well and truly outstage your
welcome
first you lead my daft grandson astray
filling that head of his with nonsense
ideas about curses
and then you come in here and smash up
my beautiful urns i mean she does have a
point you guys like to be honest
she wasn't bothering us
i'm just trying to help people if you
set foot in my basement there will be
consequences
i might even have words with your
employer
although i'd rather not see that old
weirdo again i mean a lock for a head so
strange
off with you little crow
all right guys it's going down when we
get to the basement man
she is
she is not gonna be happy when we show
up down there
all right so let's head oh wait before
we do that though oh actually no we
don't even need to plant
because what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go back
[Music]
back down here
[Music]
right here
and we're going to upgrade i think i'm
going to do strength
because i really want to make sure we're
doing lots of damage to
her all right let's go talk to the dude
down here oh wait that's looks like the
ring right there that i found
yep i'm gonna go strength man
yes
oh it also increases their reach i
forgot about that yeah after this i
think i'm gonna go for
i'm gonna start going for magic because
the haste one i get sounded really good
but i just don't really notice how much
of a difference
okay back up we go
[Music]
back into the ceramic manner
all right so are we ready to go into the
basement now like is that where this is
about to take us
let's talk to this guy
all of the voids are a glow with
unearthly light is it unlocked
if only i had a more complete
understanding of doors before you
proceed big face i have a confession to
make
the old witch of this house she is my
grandmother
she cursed me with a ceramic cranium in
a misguided effort to make me immortal
you see she was stricken with grief when
my grandfather passed and made it her
mission to keep her whole family alive
forever
now that's a really interesting take
right
like
[Music]
trying to so it's like she's not trying
to kill she really is trying to keep
people alive forever
but in doing so
she's going about it the wrong way
her research led her to believe that
replacing one's head with an urn there
you go that's what i mean by it wrong
way would somehow strike you from
death's ledges
however i resisted and during the
struggle her spell must have gone awry
for as you can see i have a pot
or a head
i fear she has gone too far beyond her
years and her soul has swollen
and grown corrupted i've seen it happen
in this land many times as a reaper i
employ to end her suffering and bring
her soul into the next life
perhaps she can find peace once again
yep here we go guys
and you know what that's gonna be a
great i'm kidding man i'm kidding could
you imagine i ended the episode right
here oh my gosh dude that's what they
would call a cliffhanger ending
no we're not doing that
be wary living reaper
oh here we go
here we go with our upgraded strength
dude
oh wait
wait what
wait it leads me back here
what in the world
i thought we were about to fight
[Music]
mimic chest
oh
no
oh
no
oh my goodness
there's stuff flying everywhere i don't
like it
i'm really focusing on just hitting the
green orbs right now because they do a
lot of damage when they hit stuff
[Music]
i am so confused as to what just
happened though
oh man they're fighting like they're
attacking faster too
yikes
[Music]
dude how about the music though
how about the music let's go
okay so you gotta use arrows on these
guys
[Music]
oh oh
[Music]
no
[Music]
all right come on i can do this man
focus
hold this up [ __ ] this up
[Music]
leave me alone
[Music]
open this up
focus on your fundamentals reaper
one more one more round dude oh no and
they saved the worst for last
it's out of the way all right i'm hoping
that the little guys will go away and
don't reappear
if i take them out
all right here we go
hold this with one health bar man
okay good deal all right
no
remember i upgraded my my string
[Music]
oh the arrow for the win
and we still hit the green ball away
let's go dude
oh man so where's the witch though right
oh my goodness
a gift to a fellow crow to aid you on
your quest
[Music]
oh a crown
oh that's pretty awesome
flame spell acquired
press left on the d-pad to switch to the
flame spell or up to switch back to
arrows
dude
oh my goodness that is freaking awesome
so now that's how we're gonna get into
her basement oh and look at that
dude this game is so good
wow
oh no
almost fell
okay let's grab this right here
[Music]
wait so i like am i gonna is it gonna be
a wall before i can get back to her
house
this episode's running on kind of long
like i don't know i don't know if you
should end it here
i mean it's kind of like a logical
endpoint but i really wanted to for us
to finish out by
by fighting the witch okay there's gotta
be a way to get over there right
what am i missing here man
what am i missing
[Music]
i don't think i'm missing anything dude
like what if i throw the fireball at it
oh come on i gotta hit it
okay yeah nothing happens
what if i hit that over there
yeah i don't think there's any way to
get that right now
what does this book say
this appears to be a reaper's abandoned
log book we've been ordered to
disconnect a series of open doors in the
region around the recent
an anomalous
anomalous yeah anomalous energy surge
this area had previously been quite
active with commission members assisting
the witch for their research the order
came through and was executed
immediately so i'm not sure what has
happened to the crows that were there
all doors must have been sealed for now
and outstanding work orders in the
region have been manually closed quite
strange but it's above my pay grade i
find it's better to not ask questions
okay
interesting
oh wait i need to find a way to i need
to hit something to get a magic
power
back oh no wait is there not a pot
anywhere i've got to find something that
i can hit you guys
something i can destroy to get my
oh up here yeah there's a little pot
right here just for that specific
purpose i bet too
yeah see it
restores itself
maybe that's why they restore is to like
constantly give you a source of
magical energy if you if you mess
something up
i better open this gate right here
hello
ah i see you've been exploring the old
office departments i used to work over
there
over in the east section before i
embrace my true life and quit the rat
race i'm much happier now but that was
once that was one lovely cozy office
okay
oh dude don't be sad
what do you got to say badger the reaper
seems like you're finding a wealth of
souls out there where are they coming
from i haven't seen so much soul energy
in decades maybe centuries
all right so wait is this that takes me
back to the ceramic manor now okay
all right well
let's go in and let's try and take out
this witch dude
open up
open up that elevator are you serious
i was about to say i didn't think i had
the key
i did not remember getting the key
[Music]
all right here we go
oh
the music
the music oh dude
furnace observation rooms okay
so i thought i was just gonna like drop
down it was time to fight her
i think we do have to end it there guys
um this has been a an incredible episode
i really enjoyed this one uh hope you
guys liked it as well if you did make
sure to give it a thumbs up we'll be
back next time and hopefully like who
knows how much longer it's gonna go
before we get to the witch i feel like
we're getting close right but
uh who knows at this point so that's why
i'm gonna go ahead and end it here but
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon